[Musique]
et c'est avec vous Gabriel la Cour des
comptes vient de publier un rapport
cinglant à l'encontre de Catherine péar
la présidente du château de Versailles
cumule des mandats limit d'âge gestion
financière plusieurs points sont abordés
dans le rapport de la Cour des comptes
nommé en 2011 par Nicolas Sarkozi
Catherine pégar a exercé trois mandats
le maximum possible aujourd'hui elle
occupe toujours ce poste par intérim en
plus des mandats elle dépasse aussi la
limite d'âge de 67 ans selon la Cour des
comptes son maintien son maintien je
cite pourrait même être assimilé à une
forme de détournement de pouvoir fin de
citation le ministère de la Culture dém
cette accusation il se défend en
expliquant que le nombre cumulé des
mandats de Catherine Pégard ne dépasse
pas celui prévu dans le décret statuaire
la situation d'intérim actuelle ne
constituant pas un nouveau mandat la
Cour des comptes pointe également des
dysfonctionnements budgétaire et réclame
un bilan de l'usage des aides publiques
octroyé pendant la crise sanitaire au
château de versaill une direction hacher
à présent où certains habitants sont en
colère oui le département a lancé fin
octobre les premiers travaux du pont
d'cher il doit relier la départementale
30 et 190 problème des habitants et des
associations environnementales se
mobilisent contre ce projet estimant que
le pont va entraîner une forte pollution
et nuire à la biodiversité un référé
suspension a été déposé aujourd'hui au
tribunal administratif de Versailles par
l'avocat du collectif une pétition
lancée en ligne réunit déjà 8 signature
une manifestation sera organisée ce
dimanche à Andry Info Trafic vous avez
une mauvaise nouvelle Gabriel pour les
automobilistes oui à partir de 22h
vendredi et jusqu'à 16h dimanche la RN10
sera fermée au niveau de trappe en
raison de travaux la Direction des
Routes d'Île-de-France doit effectuer
des opérations d'inspection sur le pont
qui do qui doit franchir provisoirement
la RN10 cela fait suite à un accident
qui a eu lieu lors des émeutes urbaines
la circulation sera impossible dans les
deux sens de déviation seront mises en
place si vous souhaitez aller en
direction de Paris il vous faudra
prendre la sortie vers la zone
d'activité de trappe et lancour si vous
souhaitez vous rendre vers le sud des
ivelines vous devrez passer par la rd912
en direction d'élancours on termine avec
un mot de sport du football Gabriel vous
allez nous parler d'un joueur ivelinois
qui a vu sa carrière décoller oui on
peut parler d'une succès story Grégory
Sikou Niakaté a commencé à jouer à 6 ans
avec le FC Saint-Germain en septembre le
joueur de 24 ans s'est envolé pour le
Portugal où il évolue en Ligue des
Champions avec le SC Braga hier c'était
son premier premier match face au Real
Madrid malgré la défaite le défenseur
central a confié à nos confrères de
l'équipe c'est exceptionnel je prends un
maximum de plaisir parce que je ne sais
pas si je revivrai ça un jour dans ma
carrière on va dire que j'étais un peu
dans le trou en France et désormais je
me frotte aux plus grands attaquants du
monde en un peu plus d'un an siikou
Niakaté et passé de remplaçant au FC
mets à titulaire avec Braga bravo à lui
et Merci à VOUS Gabriel entier on vous
retrouve dans quelques instants pour les
idées de sortie à faire ce weekend dans
les ivelines et comme d'habitude si vous
aussi prês de chez vous vous êtes témoin
d'une actualité qui vous a fait réagir
dans les Evelin n'hésitez pas à la
partager sur les réseaux sociaux en
utilisant le hashtag 78 news